because before i was really playing
every day many games and especially on
weekends there were some
training partners who came and then we
were specifically playing many hours
so you're
sorry god
it was a part of the preparation of
developing yeah
so your advice would be to
to play it earlier and then tone it tone
it down a bit
maybe that happens naturally with life
anyway because
you
you focus on other more serious things
no and you you don't have time anymore
but everybody's competitive everybody
loves chess so
i've never been an enemy of blitz games
yeah and it's so easy it's at your
fingertip right you're right you're
going waiting in a line or you're
traveling or whatever you're doing it's
in your hand so it's just really one
second away to start a game
nowadays you can do it at lunch here
you're sitting in a cafe you press a
button and you can play on your phone
like it's it's always there temptation
is too big ending everybody
but i heard he also lost last night
he lost 140 to 102 to naredinsky oh
little 240 something blitz game bullet
game match
okay
we have king g2 on the board but 96
what's he doing i see jan's faces
expression and i think he doesn't
understand things